let's get into audience questions for
the week three really good questions
submit questions however you want email
Twitter Facebook YouTube Instagram
matter now first ones from mark mark
says we hear a lot about economic
inequality and the wage gap reducing it
it increasing debates over what's
actually going on but what about
answering the question why is economic
inequality actually bad yet this this is
a good question for a couple different
reasons I mean number one it's really
important for us to consider that just
because you point out that something is
unequal doesn't necessarily mean that
it's unfair and it doesn't necessarily
mean that that inequality is bad so that
this is exactly the type of question
that I think is an important one but
you've got to talk about it in good
faith right because the arguments of
freedom and liberty dictating that
whatever inequality level results in
societies is the right one because
people should be free to do or not do
whatever they want that's not a good
argument and it also implies that the
government sort of has no role in
mitigating circumstances that are
potentially bad for everybody in society
or for specific groups so let's sort of
start there when you have a high degree
of economic inequality that gives
wealthier people a higher degree of
control over the lives of others by
virtue of being able to influence the
status quo and the systems that are in
place and in the United States when you
have a Supreme Court ruling that
effectively says that money is speech
you are you are in a practical way
codifying that and saying yes
we here money is speech if you have more
money you have more speech and we have
an extraordinarily high level of
inequality which means that when we look
at our system if we want to believe that
it is a meritocracy and a true democracy
and I know people will say David we're
not a democracy were
a constitutional republic you know what
I'm talking about here we simply don't
have that when we have this degree of
inequality that's number one number two
significant degrees of economic
inequality or what we would call a
wealth gap can also undermine the
fairness of political legal and
legislative institutions and we see that
in the United States and that I would
argue is objectively bad because you
have disenfranchisement you have the
subjugation of certain groups of people
and we could talk about what groups
those are because of the degree of
inequality that we have in the United
States we have two justice systems we
talk about that all the time when it
comes to incarceration when it comes to
street crime versus white-collar crime
versus corporate crime we have all of
those things in part because of the
degree of an economic inequality that we
that we experience and then to make a
sort of societal good argument and this
resonates with some people and it
doesn't resonate with others depending
on your political outlook the negative
externalities of extreme inequality are
a malignant it's a malignant problem in
society crime is one example we know
that when you have higher degrees of
inequality you have increasing crime
even though over a long period of time
the crime rate in the United States has
has been going down so when if we say
that an interest of the government or of
society is to reduce criminality then we
should be looking at at inequality as
something that that we could focus on
now am I suggesting that we should have
equality total equality in terms of
people's wealth and people's incomes of
course not and I actually don't know
short of actual socialists and
communists and even sometimes they make
concessions on this issue I don't know
of any Social Democrats that think that
we should have a total evening or total
equality in terms of wealth but what I
would like to see
is more aggressive taxation at the very
high level in order to sort of dampen
that very very top the people who are
hoarding money to no benefit of the
economy whatsoever and a sort of raising
of the bottom that is a way to reduce
income inequality while still allowing
successful entrepreneurs and others to
have the success that they want while
improving on a lot of these metrics at
the society level and then lastly I also
want to point out that if you support
the sort of capitalist mixed economy of
some kind or even a capitalist economy
because of innovation that you believe
that it provides inequality reduces
innovation because the innovators aren't
always the actual rich people but it's
often those that they employ or people
who are not yet rich and when you have a
high degree of inequality you are dis
incentivizing those that are not already
at the top from innovating because they
they may not perceive the benefits to be
what they potentially would be in a
different scenario they may also not be
enabled or in a situation where they can
pursue that so innovation is also hurt
by inequalities er
these are a few reasons and if your
response will be why not just work on
ending poverty rather than reducing
inequality from a strictly mathematical
standpoint if everything stays the same
except everybody who's below the poverty
level is lifted to the poverty level
that is a reduction of inequality you're
effectively calling for the same thing
then it just becomes a matter sort of of
degree and once we're talking about
degrees you've already conceded that we
should seek to reduce inequality